my first meetup was pizza you know I
know what my first meetup is my first
meetup was in two thousand eight or nine
I was doing jury duty and took my phone
out and tweeted they're like you have a
two hour break don't need a general area
I'm like what mom doesn't got a crack
right come on is like a visible and
acting with clarity hustle my name is
Gabby but I've been telling you
accountability I'm triple to heaven a
pedigree convening a pleasure my fantasy
putting the works on I'm jernard to
moving furniture seven we have a senior
specifically I had an epiphany have a
finished for my enemies with almost a
shout out community where my descendants
will be sat in the city the young
society could be putting rocks when he
clicks can examine a blast with a
formality the castle must some thinking
there might be a real opportunity for
your careers to change in a very public
so I don't mean of a census and man a
sponsor would be seven minutes props
again loss of extreme psyche itself and
immediately lost in a loop for mine when
I never had a winner miss you
taco bragged a logarithm conviction
would sell assessments on trust that
your genitals are active up in the cars
over the and in the now here page one
attract to the fill got my bachelor
biographer in that response we ready for
the traffic rifle still paranoid the
difference with a man and points are
important sitting down like prestige if
you get the rap my grandma collective of
course by Christian solitaire when I was
having commit to becoming a promise on a
goddess we've been on a roll until it's
in the pilot we're seeing is in a
childlike hope terrible one of the best
preserved in a bowl of this expect the
Western the Celtics goes that it's a
supposedly lightful where they open to
practical children and laughing together
never random is bad that is bad here for
my soul
Oh
all together double wrap it was gonna
change if it has gonna change
tell me is it never gonna change
if you have a heart attack
tell me happened on the ground trying to
throw my net worth are they a night what
social networks goddamn this is the
people don't know it again so in doubles
a nice little a couple hours of nap
little workout more like a stretch
hide up here do that excited feeling
pretty good you let the energy building
on Facebook here to probably go to do
some negotiating with this is your
business really bears what a platform
Dublin's been MIT really fun city to
watch over the last five to seven years
in the tech space a lot of big companies
have come here all off a suck a lot of
great events Web Summit was here for a
long time this event has become a big
deal I'm assuming not too long ago show
the clip recall excited it looks pretty
great talk some of the great speakers
and then quickly in Brussels so more
hotly
open till then opposed by the gross
sneezes do we thought of another one
somewhere else would be great except it
is well received today with you then oh
well the treatment I will get in the
galley
I'll try to do that try to give another
example these tunes from outside
well somebody notices not equality so we
love scatter we've got with us is
question to your electric like really
nice why don't I get a selfie me and
don't worry fantastic for tuning bet
that Thank You Rachel that's a great
sweatshirt oh man okay how are you oh
good thing we will talk later are you
have a plan okay
sure Eric now playoffs at baseball
player I guess I guess oh yeah dammit
thank you thank you for watching make
sure you follow thank you all right
thank you thank you so much darling hi
hey how are you good thank you you're
welcome
take care hi give yourself is doing I'm
not hungry yet am i from Gary do you
marry Karen I did hey Gary sleeps a
little bit yeah just a little thank you
hi how are you hi me too how are you hi
my name is my Mac or Cuba very nice to
meet you can I have yeah sure awesome so
much food you're going to hear plenty
pass hello thank you Congress oh good I
did but I don't real I'm a bad student
so I don't I go hey look at that stuff
like can i grab a coffee would you talk
for two minutes about what we're about
to do and man how are you you see ya how
are you is poking at me yet I can't wait
I understood selling stock and I'm just
a brand versus storytelling and wine was
like and they'll build for like this
wine maker you know you know do this and
what I drink
that's right so let me take you I know
you hear this a lot but you are too
inspiration for me thank you my son
honey no no right now tonight yeah am i
right so that's very nice thank you
thank you okay I going die I'll be like
oh I was going to go downstairs oh yeah
right thank you
your actual to love the shot there you
go do you rock are you hello pleasure
how are you min hello hi what's going on
what's your name what do you do I get a
lot of hustlers and and entrepreneurs
that come to me that want to be in the
tech business and they come up with
these ideas and then they want a dev
shop to build it for them and then they
launch this huge but we're going to be
the next Facebook because of this idea
and then I go you're in the tech
business and you don't have a tech
co-founder you know so I see that every
day so I think if the ambition is very
large and it's tech centric you need to
have a tech co-founder to really build
an actual big business I think if you're
building a fashion brand and there's
products like Magento and Shopify and
WordPress and already in the marketplace
and your ambition is to build a 10
million dollar scarfs business well then
you don't need to be the tech co-founder
there's tools that can get you there
through Shopify and maybe it's more
about the marketing skills or how do you
you know how do you market the crams
you know you don't really need so I
think it's I think if they go backwards
I think the thing that everybody makes
mistakes with I think one of the best
things I've ever done and I really
haven't articulated about my love of the
journey but I don't talk enough about
the way I strategize I kind of like
playing the role of like charismatic
crazy guy but I
I definitely think about quite a bit and
I think the best way to win is to know
where the hell you're going and so and
the reason I've been pushing
self-awareness is not everybody here is
destined to build a 500 million dollar
thing I also think it's crazy that if
people don't realize how amazing it is
to build a 1 million
if you can build a $1,000,000 year
revenue business and run on 30% net
price you have a crazy life and so we
have this whole world of everybody
trying to achieve for something that's
virtually impossible and they're putting
themselves in a position where by trying
to build something impossible they're
going to end up working for a bank
because the one thing that people have
in fact the vignette is globally the
economy has been pretty good for the
last decade or at least eight years and
I my biggest concern is the next
economic slowdown everybody has known
micro economic things but I think the
reality is globally right now things are
good you know things people are tense
about politics but economic realities
and if all the people that made money in
the 2000s or have family money are
pouring money into start-up land a rugby
startup can actually get money from some
individual you know that made money
prior I mean the amount of 25 and
$50,000 stupid cheques I've written in
the last five years you know and so when
that goes away what happens
hey guys don't get good well thank you
real pleasure thank you
this fills my favorite moment I always
just loved this kind of like ten seven
eight minutes before taking stage I get
home look like a like a boxer mentality
I guess you know I get very competitive
it's weird i competitive with the
audience I'm like I'm gonna [ __ ] in if
you already love me I'm gonna make you
love me more if you have no idea who I
am I'm going to make you know who I am
and if you don't like me and you're
cynical and you think I'm full of crap
you're about to be exposed so I get into
that police mentally and it's just it's
a really interesting spot it's very like
it's this incredible mixture you know
I've done this 100 times hundreds of
times at this point it's not a
nervousness but it's definitely a
different energy it's a competitive
energy of how I used to feel before
playing like more hockey in high school
when Lisa for hockey was huge in my high
school and we played it after school
like the whole school the whole school
paid more attention to intramural floor
hockey they would announce the scores to
the whole school the next morning was
like bigger than almost every team at
her high school besides the wrestling
team and literally every time I had a
game I would I would I would I love
classic I would um I would go and throw
up all my pants like in the last class
I'd have to go to bathroom because I get
so revved up that's how I get I get so
revved up are you revved up I'm sorry so
rest up
so yeah as long as hanging out at all
climb that's great thank you our office
I figured I'd try to make a challenge
and figure out awesome thank you guys
here we go
[Music]
[Music]
seven back to the reference of that well
ii-i've done this a lot I've been very
very blessed to be able to speak a whole
bunch in the last decade and I can tell
you that this is a remarkable execution
for a first year event and so I think we
should all collectively clap it up for
these [ __ ] I'm super humble to be
here I really want to focus on a couple
things I'm going to frame up this talk I
decided just now excited I pick improv
it up in clouds of dirt some of you that
pay attention to me knows what that
means for the rest of you I'll explain
it I think almost all of my success and
what I cook when I talk about my success
I want to make sure I'll use this
opportunity as well to clear that up
it's not about how much money I make
it's not if I actually buy the New York
Jets my football team that I'm trying to
buy it's that I just genuinely wake up
every day being extremely happy I'm an
extremely happy guy I I think the world
is in a much better place than the
majority of people I think that I'm an
optimist
I think there's enormous gifts and being
optimistic
I hate cynicism I think people lack
perspective I think people don't realize
the math between becoming an actual
human being when you start understanding
400 trillion to one is the odds that
you're actually sitting in this seat
it's so intense it's hard and I'm
completely driven by gratitude and so
when I think about my success as a human
living happy so that I can do my thing I
think about it in clouds and dirt and I
think about it in clouds and dirt in my
success of being an entrepreneur as well
and when I understood the diversity of
the audience watching here and watching
in live streaming I thought it was the
right place to go because whether you're
a start-up founder or whether you're an
executive or whether you're an
entrepreneur or a student what
you're 18 or 81 the one thing that has
been consistent in success when I
analyzed it is this notion of clouds and
dirt and what I mean by that is the
following for example there's a lot of
marketers in here and the reason I
believe that they will not be macro
successful to their ambitions or their
wants and dreams is because they're just
headline readers they're just in the
clouds right they've read the articles
they've read the books they've heard the
speices they've heard somebody say
Facebook Ads don't work they've heard
somebody say Facebook Ads do work
they've heard people say snapchat
doesn't matter anymore because Instagram
copied the features they talk and theory
they lack being a practitioner others
are in the dirt and so for me it's all
about top-line strategy and so my top
line strategy nine years ago was this
that this was going to become the
primary device and that not only was it
going to be the remote control of our
lives but that this would become the
television and the television would
become the radio and so nine years ago I
basically committed my life to
understanding this through the
television and that Facebook Twitter
Instagram uses for the BBC and CBS NBC
and CNN sky met and I was going to
figure out how to make the best shows on
it whether that was me whether that was
Wine Library was that was my clients and
I promise you that that thesis has
worked out and I implore everybody here
to start thinking about their lives in
success right from a clouds and dirt
perspective I loved the last
presentation I guarantee listen to
anything I can see no content and so
much of what I heard as I was getting
ready was so right and makes me think a
lot about how I was parented and how I
want to parent right my macro clouds in
being a parent is I want my children to
be as happy as I am because I'm real
[ __ ] happy
so that's why clouds it's simple right
most parents tie their own self-esteem
into their kids accomplishments that's
why they put stickers what they did in
school or what club they're part of I
don't care if my kids want to be
entrepreneurs not outdoors if my
daughter wants to make paintings out of
tomatoes she'll she'll get my support
1,000% I want to reverse engineer exam I
want to know what they want to do right
that's my macro then my micro is the
details of that the actual practitioners
ship around that like how much the
tomatoes cost right like that and I
believe that nineteen ninety nine
percent of this room
plays in the middle of clouds and dirt I
believe that the marketplace in the
middle a they don't have top-line
strategies and understand where the
rolls going and be they get fancy and
they don't want to get their hands dirty
much like my intro which I appreciate
reason I stopped and took a selfie and
said hello and shook hands is who the
[ __ ] am I like do you know what kind of
feeling it is to have people admire what
you do you know nice cities do you know
how nice it is that somebody will be mu
and say hey like do you understand what
that feels like you have to pull from
opposite directions clouds and dirt
that's called really big [ __ ] ego and
really massive humility stop [ __ ]
complaining thank you
[Applause]
one you committed you're auditioning
right - you have to figure out if what
you're doing now is just the place where
you're transitioning into the next
chapter your career or just the thing
that you want to try to build and so if
you actually decided from a strategical
standpoint the next 2-3 years is really
just about learning less posturing
faking it to make it more just learning
tasting it understanding the grass is
not always greener
yeah startup land is better than Finance
learn because people aren't as douchey
or this map but there's a lot of things
that aren't as good like pressure like
it's all on you like the desert is a
done well then if you lead the macro
decision but this is a stepping stone
and this is how you're going to go about
the world all of a sudden you're not
spending most of your time trying to
figure out how to make the most money
out of this you're taking it in a
totally different mindset you've almost
got a university like mentality to the
execution you don't want to go out of
business you don't want to have to go
back to get a job pushing patients got
so much more time that's what's going to
trip you up you want it to fast
everybody L wants it too bad this is
advice I'm giving you know giving advice
to everybody right now you really have
to know what you're doing like at the
macro and the other thing is you have to
be flexible enough to know the changes
what your ambition is that at 19 and 15
and 22 is different than what your
mission is at 41 and you have to be
flexible in that reality so I think it's
a it's a strategic answer you know and I
think that um I think you need to think
about I think you need to think about
tasting everything because you're a
young man you want to figure out what
the hell you like and what you're good
at
there's an incredible you know like kind
of access point of like what you're
great at and what you love when you
stumble into being somebody like me
you really win when what you're
naturally great at is what you naturally
love the most and away you go
the amount of people that I meet every
day that are great at something have no
interest in being a CFO they love their
insane with numbers but they don't want
to do it they want to sing right or you
know like and so that's tough you see it
in athletics like people don't
understand athletes the amount of
athletes that just do it because it was
the best way in the same way that
somebody goes and becomes an accountant
and they don't love competition and they
don't love the sport it's crazy you know
when you look at them because like you
wanted to fifteen that you know and they
don't love it which is why they're not
the greatest athlete of all time the
greatest athlete of all time are the
ones who love it and have it and so I
think what you need to do is taste
everything
I like food you know your favorite food
is if you only eat one food that's why I
love to write Supremes writing right
it's where I can do my 301 course
instead of my one-on-one courses we know
one course Iraq that's where that's how
are you so I would take advantage of
your youth and and your flexibility have
this kind of age and try to taste
everything play with everything figure
out what you might be good at what you
might like and then you make a decision
you know when I think about being 41
years old and feeling as young as I feel
like I'm ten years old I said Gary Vee
take over I'm stealing people [ __ ]
snapchats
how we do it got a little atlantic here
but I feel like I have my whole life in
front of me and I think it's very
difficult for youngsters to realize that
I where I'm sure some of us that have
lived a little bit longer you know you
just don't like when I was 20 how are
you well I was 26 41 seemed like [ __ ]
long way away you know like like my
eight my eight year old cousin eight
years older cousin who worked with me at
Wine Library speak old to me and you
know he was 34 when I was 26 so 41
[ __ ] like like it's funny for me to
think about like how you're seeing me
but I'm telling you
feel exactly the way you feel right now
at 41 and so that's interesting because
when people understand that you can
start deploying more patience because
right now you want to prove it you've
got right yeah quickly you know I can
read that because you're in the fakie
like first words down your mouth always
such an indicator of what's on your mind
you know I don't I never care to fake it
till I made it because I think here what
people thought how are you Eddie is my
birthday today
yes you're going to die so do something
about it pleasure
real pleasure manners continue to
assassinate when you can eliminate that
[ __ ] changes real quick you know even
think about high school and I'm going
into college like high school so tough
for people because that's the apex of
when everything is about what other
people think and then you love the
transition the university or the last
year of high school cuz you care a
little less right but those first couple
years of high school I don't know the
school system exactly I do here but like
if like everybody's wrapped up in that
12 to 17 year old age of like
everything's about what everybody else
thinks oh that's why so many people hate
that Iran
I just never went through that luckily
hardwiring good parenting serendipity
circumstance wrapping my self-esteem and
things that I was great at not really
not really good at thinking about what
I'm bad at even interviews the only time
I get stumped is they're like what do
you struggle with or what what's a
failure I'm like I just don't even like
quantify it I don't think it's worth it
I think people dwell too much you sure
can never think Skyy that's a pink sky
like pink sky do you rock you rock loves
pink skies I had any strategy today
which is I do a little thought to the
first thing which I decided was clouds
and dirt and I'd then thematically
improvident the whole way it's cool what
I did like those good but that was cool
you know what my first meetup is my
first meetup was in two thousand eight
or nine I was doing jury duty and took
my phone out and tweeted they're like
you have a two-hour break but don't
leave the general area I'm like rot and
this was before being hers
oh yes before Boehner had an office I
was in New Jersey there's nowhere to go
I couldn't get back to you Upper East
Side like so I was like look opened up
Google I like it was like I have an idea
I'm going to open up Google Maps well
there's a pizza shop looks like tweet
them like hey I'm going this pizza shop
like and like seven people showed up
yeah and that was like that's before
meetups right like that
Fona just come out and I was like this
is cool la
thank you very solid leather fantasy
dissonance I had an epiphany having
finished sorry for my enemies I met
another so change in unity what works
only in a pension Who am I to whom he
sat in the city if I get his to be
putting box when he clicks any God but
he black aside for Mohammed either died
from a child yes with no hope for me
logo from a rope so he so don't be
nervous Enter Sandman and fossil of
beaches seven minutes passing your loss
and asleep I get all from the Queen
liberal syllable revival I never settle
with a man
Kaka bad days are critical never be
convicted open house it would say that
sometimes like antennas orders are more
active husband flies over the head is
and now here pay for the tractor to
filled I'm a bachelor but the I never
been nervous once we ready for the
traffic rifle still paranoid is the
difference with a man employed are
important city town like crazy if you
get the wrap my brain with a
collectivist or electricity intelligence
tell what the hell was that we can this
you become common organic we've another
ultimate color to the planet right and
it's going to wake up at 1:30 in the
morning to do something pretty cool for
the same of the apps secret thing you'll
know about it
you'll reference this you'll reference
this when you reference it but um good
day Dublin I love you Brussels I'm about
to love you yeah alrighty rock wants the
vlog to be better so
we're going to pieces we landed in this
is what you get when you try to produce
mulready here we go explain watch it
yesterday I left New York City and I
landed in Dublin this morning at 6:00
a.m. or so 7 a.m.
boy boy met a fad you guys offer that
I'm even the driver knows right we've
been hanging out for half a day